he's the kind of person we should listen
to there's a reason he rose in such
popularity because people are resonating
with his ideas now even if I don't I can
at least recognize well here's a voice
maybe I should pay attention to I might
learn something from him hey I'm Dave
Rubin and this is the Rubin report
reminder everybody you can get all our
videos and audio podcasts absolutely ad
free and early at Rubin report comm and
joining me today is the publisher of
skeptic magazine host of the science
salon podcast and author of the new book
giving the devil his due
Michael Shermer welcome back to the
Rubin report good to be back the
Tournament of Champions continues we've
had a couple technical difficulties
today to make this thing happen but here
we are I I know that as a man of faith
you're gonna pray that our attention
doesn't I'm praying away I'm not gonna
try to pray away the gay for you but I'm
gonna try to pray away the coronavirus
bugs in our computer systems here it's
the 5g you see oh it's definitely it's
definitely the 5g it's coming for
everybody it's spreading Corona of ice
the corona virus and the rest of it all
right there's a ton I want to get to
here because I really love this book and
I just said to you right before we
started that so much in in my book is
well we really cover the topics but come
to slightly different conclusions on a
couple things and the way we approach
the topics is a little bit different
each time but before we get to the book
itself you've written 16 books and as a
guy that just wrote one and knows what
it takes to write one how do you
possibly not only come up with enough
material but enough sort of personal
fortitude and patience and and all of it
to just be able to sit there and put all
of those thoughts out 16 times and quite
successfully by the way it's not like
nobody's reading these things you know
well thank you I appreciate that well
first of all I'm 65 so I've got a couple
decades on you're almost just cumulative
time but I also started writing in my
20s when I was in college I actually
always wanted to be a writer and then by
the time I got to my early 30s I had
written
a bit that wasn't published just you
know just practicing stuff and trying to
get things published such that by my
first book let's see in 1997 so I was 30
let's see 33 no let's see no 43 you know
I had had quite a bit of material so and
43 at my first book with you see that's
right but so each book kind of ends with
a question of sorts or in my mind anyway
that's the next book and it's also a
strategy when you're cutting because I
always I usually write too much material
and I think oh I'd really don't want to
give this up and I can talk myself into
doing that by saying I'll put it in the
next book and then it shortens that book
so you don't feel like you've wasted
your time but person by temperament I
feel like if I don't write pretty much
every day it's like if I don't go work
out if I don't ride my bike I feel
anxious like I really need to write I
just have kind of a need for it and I
know other people like you know Isaac
Asimov was like that way apparently
Stephen King's like that they just got a
cranked out the material because it
feels good it's just sort of what I do
you know like the an artist paints I
write whatever and so I find a lot of
you know it's not a chore I don't have
you know writer's block per se a time
block I just said you know I just need
more time because I enjoy it one of the
things that I really like that you do
and it's not just in this book it's it's
in I really all of your books or at
least the last few since I've known you
is you give credit to a lot of the other
current thinkers that are talking about
these things and I think that's a that's
actually a kind of unique trait because
a lot of people want to sort of sit
there and make it seem like they came up
with all this but even I was looking at
the I was looking at the blurbs in the
back of the book and and actually it's a
it's a Rubin report reunion over here
because you've got Steven Pinker Jordan
Peterson maybe in Strawson Nick
Christakis Amy Chua and Jonathan hate
and I reference they've all been on the
show which which is nice but but that is
one of the things that I like about this
book because you reference a lot of
these people and their ideas as sort of
the starting point for starting point or
maybe midpoint for how you think about
things were you always that way that you
would sort of hear somebody and kind of
mirror what you think against them yeah
to a certain extent but as a writer and
as a consumer of many other books I can
see some authors are more generous about
crediting where their ideas came from
and and sort of tracking for the reader
how they came up with their thesis of
the book or whatever others not so much
I'm not gonna name any names but some
people do write in a way like they just
came out of this whole cloth it just
popped into my brain like the muses you
know and that no ideas happen like that
we all build on each other everybody
does and you know in scholarly papers
you have to cite just tons and tons and
tons of references you know and that's
why sometimes the reference sections are
as long as the papers themselves so you
know so I always felt like well I want
to be generous and just sort of honest
and say that here's where I came up with
these ideas because of these three
authors or these 16 sources or whatever
anyway so I just got in the habit of
doing that just from training as a
experimental psychologist initially and
then a historian of science you just
have to do that but just personally I
feel you know when I see that someone
like Richard Dawkins is very generous
about that he's his deep thinker you
know deciding where all these ideas come
from quoting other people and it's like
I like that I'm gonna I want to make
sure I do that too yeah so one other
thing before we dive specifically into
the topics in the book because you have
now been on the Rubin report at least
six times which places you at number one
which I'm sure despite your despite your
rather lofty resume I'm sure that's
clearly at the top of the list but for
somebody that's watching this right now
that just doesn't know anything about
you can you just give me a two or
three-minute sort of recap on on how you
kind of became the skeptic skeptic yeah
well you know my day job is publishing
skeptic magazine and directing the
skeptic Society which is a 501 C 3
non-profit science education
organization I got interested in the
topics which is pretty much any of the
super interesting topics related to
science and religion and spirituality
and cults and free will and determinism
and God you know you know pretty much
all the great topics I'm interested in
really goes back to being in college and
I was a born-again Christian I was in
1971 when I was in 11th grade I had two
close friends who were interested in
converting me I didn't even know what
that meant really and George and Frank
so George had a really cute sister and
invited me to church I thought well okay
here's my chance but but then I got to
the church it was Presbyterian Church in
Glendale California and that that
Minister was unbelievably dynamic and
just really motivating and at the end he
said come on up and you can accept Jesus
the whole thing will happen right here
and I'm like all right I'm going so I
didn't even know I was doing really but
I did it and then you know took it
pretty seriously and then I went to
Pepperdine University which is a Church
of Christ cool and very conservatives
and you know Gerald Ford came to speak
and Edward Teller even gave his mutual
assured destruction speech and everyone
was 9 right and Atlas Shrugged and all
that you know pretty much the what you'd
expect but then when I went to graduate
school I kind of drifted away from being
religious mainly but for two reasons one
you know studying social psychology
anthropology sociology you know I could
see that other people's religious belief
systems are very much context dependent
geographically dependent you know had I
been born in India I very likely would
not be Christian had I been born 10,000
years ago that there would be no
Christians right so you know it's it
seemed to me that that that doesn't make
it wrong but it makes it more likely to
to be mythically true as our friend
Peterson would say not empirically true
and we're gonna get into that yeah yeah
so but but then also the problem of evil
that theodicy well you know why bad
things happen to good people and and I'm
not talking about you know like human
volition of homicide or war or something
like that but just like innocent
children dying of leukemia or you know
thousands of children dying from
starvation every year and so on it's
like why would a good God allow that to
happen I know there's tons of books and
papers by theists and theologians about
this but to me they've never squared
that circle they've never solved that
problem other than like rabbi Kushner's
famous book when bad things happen to
good people his conclusion was God
simply can't do anything about it he's
just not on he's not omniscient
I mean he's not omnipotent he may know
everything but he can't stop evil okay
so that's one solution
another one is well there just is and
and that's the simpler solution and that
explains a lot because if you understand
the laws of physics and say the second
law of thermodynamics entropy just [ __ ]
happens
you know just it's mostly just random
and you know there's very little
directionality to why things happen
other than just statistical
probabilities and that's it there's
nothing to explain you know it's like
coronavirus what's the cause you know
five hundred years ago it would have
been you know well women have been
cavorting with demons in the middle of
the night or the Jews poison the well or
you know some of these in a crazy
supernatural paranormal and racist
bigoted targeting of people's to explode
well we don't do that anymore except for
the 5g craziness because you know we
live in an age of science and hopefully
we've moved past that so to me once I
left the church and really religion I
was still interested in answering the
big questions like well then where did
the universe came from if there's no God
what's the origins of morality
what about consciousness and you know
why is the universe tuned the way it is
where'd all this diversity of life come
from and you know all the great
questions from a secular perspective so
in trying to answer it myself I thought
well I want to write some this is what
I'm gonna write about from a skeptical
perspective so my little niche my lane
as they say is you know kind of on the
margins of science the pseudoscience and
the paranormal the supernatural the sort
of controversial stuff that most
mainstream scientists don't deal with
that's my lane and from there I can
tackle the great questions just from my
particular perspective you know so like
I have a chapter in the book you know
mr. Hume tear down this wall and the one
before it defending scientific humanism
the point of that you know so I'm trying
to get away from this this kind of Noma
as Steve Gould called it non-overlapping
magisteria where you know Gould argued
and most scientists tend to go this way
is that you know that science and
religion are two different things and
that you scientists get the empirical
world and the religious people they get
the world of morality and meaning and
purpose and I'm like wait a minute why
can't we say something about that I mean
I don't believe in God but I still
believe that their objective moral
values how can that be because there's
no outside source
well here's how it could be so I try to
defend that and now that there is a
technical problem called the
naturalistic fallacy that my philosopher
friends tell me is not you can't debunk
it so I try to debunk it they tell me
well you didn't quite do it but I I'm
not a philosopher I'm not trying to
pretend to be one I'm just saying it's
not a choice between you either believe
in God and you go for the religious
morality or you're a relativist and
anything goes you can never say
something is wrong I don't like slavery
but I can't say it's wrong I don't I
don't think the Jew should have been
exterminated in the Holocaust but I
can't say it's really wrong to
exterminate Jews are you kidding me yes
of course we can say it's wrong okay
anyway so that's kind of where I'm
coming from okay man you have teed me up
with so much stuff there and and much of
what you just described is in the book
and I really do want to spend some time
focusing on this sort of mystical truth
as you describe through the Jordan
Peterson lens and and the empirical
truth and the rest of it and and we
talked about this I just did your
podcast and we've come to slightly
different conclusions on it and yet
we're here and we're still not killing
each other so what I want to start with
first though is just is just the title
actually of the book because that really
struck me giving the devil his due
seems actually quite reverse of the way
that most of us behave these days
perhaps not the two of us right this
very moment but but so much of society
seems to be based on not giving the
devil his due just finding oh someone
thinks something differently than me
that must mean that everything they
think and the summation of who they are
is somehow evil and wrong so when you
came up with the title was that did that
have a lot to do with just sort of how
we seem to behave like right now yes
yeah I mean absolutely I'm just finding
that the page where I want to start on
this how this problem started because
free speech and free thought that used
to be a liberal cause I mean that was
you know free speech UC Berkeley 1960's
we're gonna stand up and think and and
say whatever we want and you know the
comedian's of this 50s and 60s they're
pushing back against the man you know
the power authority which was mostly the
right in the Christian Right and
Republicans and it was remember at the
time most Republicans mostly wanting to
censor things like burning the flag or
Madonna's videos or
or whatever because their argument was
well this could harm society you know
people expressing themselves in a
certain way can bring down the moral
values of our great god-given you know
whatever country and therefore we have
to combat that in a way the left is now
doing that saying well you know certain
speech is harmful and harmful this is a
form of violence and there and and we
have to prevent violence and therefore
censoring speech is okay that's kind of
the the thread and it really goes back I
identify in the first page of the book
this goes back to 1919 in the case of
Schank versus the United States so this
is the famous decision by this Supreme
Court justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
where the shouting fire in a theatre and
clear and present danger phrases come
from so here is his decision the most
stringent protection of free speech
would not protect a man in falsely
shouting fire in a theatre in causing a
panic the question in every case is
whether the words used are used in such
circumstances and are of such a nature
as to create a clear and present danger
that they will bring about substantive
evils that Congress has a right to
prevent okay what was this clear and
present danger
this guy shank was the head of the
Socialist Party in Philadelphia and he
was printing and handing out flyers to
draft age young men who were being
drafted
you know conscription was legal and they
were being drafted and sent to Europe to
die for our country and Schenk said wait
a minute that's a violation of the
Fourteenth Amendment which protects your
bodily autonomy and right and no one can
take away your life but in a way
conscription in the draft that that's a
way of the government saying we're
taking over your life for a while and
you may die if we order you to go do
that
whoa okay now you we can debate that
that's a separate issue the thing is how
can that be a clear and present danger
that's the equivalent of crowd shouting
fire in a crowded theater well now by
the 1960s of course everybody's
protesting the draft and burning their
draft cards and running up to Canada or
whatever and that was a liberal cause to
say you know what that that's going too
far you know it has to be okay to have
those kinds of debates and discussions
and protests that's all protected by the
Constitution here's the US Supreme Court
saying no no we can step in and okay so
fast for
to say the civil rights movement and the
push in the 70s and 80s to improve our
speech right okay so don't use the
n-word you know that that's really
harmful okay pretty much everybody go
yeah yeah that's that's right okay and
by the way the c-word for women and
calling Jews [ __ ] sand and Vietnamese
gooks and that the bin starts getting
bigger and bigger like yeah that's
hateful it's so harmful and and
therefore it should be censored so it
starts off with good intentions on the
part of the left like yeah yeah that's
and that this moral progress starts but
then by the 90s you get you know that
the bin is getting larger and then by
you know a couple years ago when I
reprinted in there the UC systems list
of microaggressions that are harmful
hateful things to say things like where
are you from or wow you speak English so
well or why aren't you good at math or
you are gonna write you have a whole
chart laying this out yeah so you know
the whole trees things out but yeah so
are you surprised though the way the
mission creep has affected institutions
that were supposed to defend these
liberal principles I mean the easiest
one I can give you is nadine strossen
who you have the blurb on the back of
the book she was the head of the aclu
she is a free speech absolutist she no
longer is the head now she's since
retired but she laid out in this very
room the very strong case for why the
Nazis should have been allowed to march
in Skokie versal annoy it was a place
where there was a tremendous amount of
Holocaust survivors but the ACLU
defended the freedom of speech of a
group of odious people because that's
what we're supposed to do in this
country we're now even the ACLU is often
suddenly seemingly on the wrong side of
these things are you surprised but it's
not just affected individual people but
the way that the mission creep has
affected the institutions that were
supposed to stand up for this stuff that
it has and I'm worried about that I
don't know if they actually believe it
or if they're just scared that they're
gonna be canceled and and censored
themselves or whatever you know I'm
somewhat sympathetic to some university
administrators say who kind of go along
with it because they're scared of losing
their jobs or professors are afraid to
say something but
but but this is the problem they should
this the whole reason for tenure in the
first place was to protect liberal
professors from these right-wing coops
who wanted to shut them down now it's
kind of reversed and so maybe we do need
tenure to protect these liberal
professors from their fellow leftists or
fellow liberals who want to cancel them
to shut them down get them fired this is
a perverse reversal of things that you
know it's just gone haywire I mean so
the devil in the title is whoever you
disagree with and whoever disagrees with
you or you don't like or you don't like
what they say I mean it's easy to grant
free speech to people you agree with
that's know who it's for it's for the
people that that don't agree with you
those are the voices we have to hear
okay so to articulate the reasons simply
you know one person's hate speech is
another person's free speech so I got
this from nadine strossen book that in
the 1850s southern politicians argued
that abolitionists from the north coming
into the south to give sermons and
speeches and and distribute pamphlets
about the evils of slavery that's a form
of hate speech no they didn't use that
word hate speech but that basically made
the argument that Justice Holmes made
was that this could lead to slave diets
in insurrections and that could lead to
the murder of slave owners and the
disruption of our peaceful plantation
life here in the South and therefore we
have to censor that it's like wow if
they hadn't had this opportunity to
champion the abolition of slavery would
we ever have gotten there and then in
the 1960s there were arguments in the
South again made against Malcolm X
particular and Martin Luther King
slightly less that what they were saying
was what was a they again didn't use the
word hate speech but that this is
potentially dangerous to have them
coming down here to give these sermons
and speeches that rile people up and
they go out in the streets to protest
wow we can't have that well they will
hate a minute that's how social change
happens that's protected in the
Constitution and again these are liberal
causes that by now it's kind of flipped
so we have to remind ourselves trying to
do in this book is that no no here are
the reasons okay so I articulate them
like they did
Nadine did on your show you know it's
it's like even if you're completely
right you can learn something from
somebody else's arguments to improve
your own arguments as John Stuart Mill
said he who knows his own side only his
own side of the case doesn't even know
that right so like I have my students
watch Ben Shapiro's videos arguing
pro-life and because most of them they
don't know what the pro-life arguments
are and it's like so even if you end up
being pro-choice at the end you still
you're better off now but but maybe
Ben's right about some points or
whatever the other side is maybe you're
completely wrong and you can learn
something new but mostly the devil part
here is is for my safety sake also that
if once I set up the norms or laws or
customs or whatever to silence you well
what happens if I'm now in the minority
position or I have the voice that goes
against the grain then then I've I've
already endorsed the apparatus to shut
me down and so that's that's the best
argument if you want to take it from
kind of a selfish perspective to give
the devil is do for your own safety sake
yeah and we see a lot of that these days
which is you know the people who are
running around screaming that Trump is
Hitler are the ones that are also saying
that the federal government isn't doing
enough it's the same sort of idea like
oh well then maybe we should staling
back if you were right in the first
place but putting that aside for a
second so let's so I think this will
lead us to what I think is really like
the most interesting stuff here as you
talk about the way liberals have sort of
maybe lost the plot along the way do you
think that there is a weakness in
liberalism and I think this will sort of
get us also to the Jordan mystical
versus imperial imperial truth part of
this do you think that there's a
weakness in the ideology of liberalism
of the openness of liberalism that
allows for all of the bad ideas to come
in which sort of leads us to a place
right now where liberals often don't
know what they believe while
conservatives at the moment seem to have
a better ability to fight off the social
justice stuff the intersectionality
stuff the progressive rot that we sort
of see across society right now is there
something that is actually weak in the
very system of ideas that I know you and
I
you know mostly subscribe to yeah I want
liberals to own the First Amendment like
conservatives own the Second Amendment
right I mean it's just saying yes thank
rose say you're never giving this up
we're drawing the line in the say this
is it okay and but but they they've
they've abandoned that in a way I think
an explanation might come from karl
popper's the great philosopher of
science karl popper's book the open
society and so he made the argument that
there's something of a paradox of being
tolerant of intolerance and then
therefore the intolerant people can rise
to power because you've tolerated them
and then they shut the whole system now
this is kind of the argument in
simplicity it's it's a it's an issue
that we should deal with but I'm not
particularly worried about that I think
that's taking the precautionary
principle like just in case the
intolerant people you know come to come
to power we can't have that so we should
start shutting people down well who do
you shut down you know the ones that we
think are intolerant who you that you
think what we gonna have a karate set up
that decides this and again pretty soon
you're shutting down you know this
person in that person and half the
country shut down and this is no good
right so but I think it's a bad and that
liberalism can do is there something
that liberalism can do to defend itself
from that because of that paradox right
I mean I'll grant you that liberals are
sort of liberals are more open that's
the idea of liberalism that comes with a
lot of good stuff like individual rights
and freedom but then that openness and
this is exactly what popper was talking
about allows these guys to come in and
then liberals seemed to scatter when
when the going gets rough because they
don't want to be called bigots and Nazis
and the rest of it well of course no one
wants to be called that but the problem
is is that you have to allow people to
say things like that again for your own
safety sake it's a foundational
principle of all the other rights it
stands below them it's the sort of
foundational rock upon say the pyramid
platform upon which all the other stones
are built those being the other rights
if if you don't have the freedom to
think and say what you want then all the
other rights that come from protesting
from you know writing speaking better
ideas to replace the bad ideas which is
much the history of civilization is just
the improvement of our understanding of
the cause of things in the world that's
the only way to do it so I to me the
Liberals have to just remind themselves
of that foundational principle you know
but but but also you know just sort of
own that as like this is where we draw
the line in the sand and and and just
sort of this idea of diversity so it's a
small step to say you're in favor of
diversity oh yeah totally
how about diversity of viewpoints is
it's called viewpoint diversity you know
you have to put that in the same bin and
that's where of course you as you know
they get to get a little crazy about
that so this is a good segue for us
because what I'm finding right now is
that line in the sand that we both want
drawn it seems impossible for liberals
to do at a systemic level meaning the
individuals we've talked about this many
times that I believe individuals can do
it but it seems like systems based on
that seem unable to unable to stand up
to it so I thought this will be a great
segue to talk about the the differences
that you have with Jordan Peterson I
thought I have to read actually the
blurb that Jordan wrote on the back of
the book because I've literally never
seen a statement like this written on
the back of someone's book before and
that'll be a good launch point for us so
Jordan wrote this is a rather difficult
book for me to blurb given that an
entire chapter is devoted to criticizing
my claims about pragmatic truth visa vie
scientific truth however dr. Michael
Shermer is a very clear thinker and the
kind of skeptic that is always necessary
to ensure that the public thought
scientific and otherwise maintains a
certain clarity he's a passionate
advocate of free speech for this and
many other reasons to the point of
entitling his new book giving the devil
his due which is devoted to many
worthwhile topics but to free speech
above all despite our disagreements this
is a necessary book for our times read
it and thank God and the powers that be
that you have the right to do so so I
think it's sort of perfect because it's
it's a summation of what we all know
about Jordan but the fact that you asked
him to do it despite having a chapter in
here which grapples with all
of his ideas and I do think this is sort
of linked to the question that I'm
asking you about liberalism so can you
sort of unpack what your similarities
and differences are with Jordan yeah I
think you know when I first saw Jordan
on your show and Joe show and so who is
this guy you know like everybody else
like who is this guy to me I was dying
to know what it is he thought about
things although at the same time I could
see mostly liberals again trying to shut
him down or call him Hitler whatever I
mean a bigot and a misogynist and and
whatnot and then when I met him I
thought this guy is a super good guy I
mean I I could see why I don't agree
with him on this and that but you know
he's the kind of person we should listen
to there's a reason he rose in such
popularity because people are resonating
with his ideas now even if I don't I can
at least recognize well here's a voice
maybe I should pay attention to I might
learn something from him and so the two
chapters at the end of the book that
chapter on Jordan in the chapter on
Graham Hancock who I was on Joe Rogan's
podcast with and then I got to know it's
like okay this guy's an alternative
archaeologist he has some ideas that
most archaeologists think you're crazy
or way out there not substantiated and
and yet he makes some pretty good
arguments he's a great writer and you
know from there I think you know this is
the kind of people we got to give a
voice to and and acknowledge that you
know maybe we don't have time to listen
to every single person out there but you
know pick and choose the ones that are
very popular because they must be saying
something that resonates with people now
Jordan's theory of truth you know it's
sort of a blend of Charles Darwin and
William James sort of a pragma
evolutionary pragmatism and I don't want
to you know misquote his his theory you
can listen to for hours him and say I'm
kind of hashing this out it goes on for
that long and in his books kind of
deconstruct all that but near as I could
tell it would be something like you know
if if you believe it's true and it and
it works pragmatically speaking then
that then you can use the word truth to
it and I think it comes down to what do
you mean by that like so did was Jesus
resurrected from the dead now
most Christians today say yes you know
absolutely yeah someone named Jesus
existed he
crucified and he rose from the dead and
you know 100 billion people have lived
and died before the seven and a half
billion people alive now not one of them
is back from the dead except this one
maybe okay so that's that's the argument
now from a skeptics perspective I would
say well that is an extraordinary claim
how extraordinary a hundred billion to
one extraordinary right is the evidence
for it corresponding or in proportion to
that hundred billion to one odds and and
the answer is no and you know so I write
about that but but to Jordan I think he
would say whether it happened or not is
irrelevant
it's mythically true or psychologically
true that is you have a cross to bear
you might say a burden to carry of the
suffering of yourself and your family
and friends or humanity or whatever
forgiveness you know starting over this
kind of resurrection of your own life to
rebuild its like the noachian flood
story it's it's a story of sort of
destruction and redemption it's a kind
of a born-again story so I think what
Jordan is arguing is that has mythic
power that is a kind of truth that's
sort of like Myrtle an eternal truth
underneath the empirical truth something
like that right right that's right so it
could be that people like me and Jordan
or someone like maybe Richard Dawkins
and Jordan or whoever that's kind of an
empiricist they're just talking at two
different levels I think you know
Jordan's not always super clear about
this so you have to kind of read what he
said here there or whatever but I think
that's what's going on and so to the
extent that you know he likes to quote
Jung and Freud and Nietzsche and and and
Tolstoy and so on it's like you know
Shakespeare Jane Austen the reason this
is great literature is because it's
tapping something about the reality of
human nature human relationships
societies conflict power struggles sex
and gossip and you know conflict and
violence war those are all realities
that everybody knows and these great
novelists can tap into that there's a
whole study now of evolutionary literary
sort of evolutionary psychology of
literature
where they kind of they do a content
analysis of great works to see which
kind of themes come up over and over and
over and they're the deepest themes that
we all care about again that you know
the sort of hierarchy social status
power deception honesty love sex all
that and and so they're I think what
Jordan is arguing that I would agree
with that there are truths there now
that's a but that's different than an
empirical truth like you so the analogy
I make is like people will often send me
as the other of skeptic magazine
articles explaining what really happened
with the flood you know a meteor striker
was a volcano eruption not the flood
like this the parting of the Red Sea say
the flood also or the Jesus was on the
cross and then somebody gave him this
chemical through the rag and that put
him into a coma and then they put him in
the tomb and then he woke up and then
his disciples whisked him off to France
and any minute he and he married Mary
Magdalene and they had kids and and and
and the bloodline is still around this
was of course Dan Brown's novel that was
a real book actually before Dan Brown
was a book called Holy Blood Holy Grail
and and that they actually those guys
sued Dan Brown for stealing their idea
he's like it's a novel dude right yeah
yeah yeah he sold so many books it man
if you don't sell any books no one's
gonna see you because there's no money
right so it was kind of fun but there
you saw the difference you know dant dan
brown's novel resonated because it's
it's just a story
he's not claiming it's empirically true
but these guys the Holy Blood Holy Grail
authors that you know they were saying
no no this really happened okay so those
are two different ways of saying really
happened or truth you know so do you
think it's possible that we need both of
those I think maybe that's the position
that I've come around to that we need
empirical truths we need scientific
truths absolutely but when you talk
about that that other layer that Jordans
talking about the sort of time-tested
things about purpose and happiness and
and individualism and the drive to to
accomplish what humans are sort of here
to do that's for me I've come to and
this is this is one of the spots than
when I was just on your show you were
you were asking about because I write
about this in my book I've come to the
place where for a society to organize
its
properly it does need some other ethos
beneath it and what I think is something
like when you talk about Shakespeare and
all the authors that write about these
themes - that in and of themselves those
stories aren't enough to organize a
society around not that again that
individuals can't do it but for actually
for a society to function properly do
you do you think there's some truth to
that
yeah I do for sure I mean there's a
reason why drama films and television
sells or has much bigger viewership than
documentary films I mean it's very rare
any documentary film gets you know
millions of views there's a few but not
many and and and the reason is is
because we're storytelling animals and
we're moved
emotionally deeply psychologically moved
by a story you know about some person
now like when Spielberg made Schindler's
List you know it's not a story of the
Holocaust because you know that's too
big a subject I mean you'd have you
could have like a Ken Burns thirteen
part series on the Holocaust people have
done this because there's so many
stories instead he just took one little
story okay this guy Oskar Schindler who
was this guy and you know connealy wrote
that novel about him sort of a semi true
novel okay so if you really look at it
it's not that interesting the story but
when you're bringing on the big screen
and then you build in the Holocaust
around that story but it's the narrative
thread that goes throughout so all
filmmakers know this most of us
nonfiction writers we don't understand
you got to have a narrative story you
know you got to have an arc to it right
poles right rolls readers along good
writers do that and film it good
filmmakers do this so there's there is
something in the human mind about you
know sort of grasping ideas and holding
them in a way that you know giving a
yammering away at a blackboard giving a
lecture which is like do for a living
that's not nearly as powerful as
somebody who could just tell one story
about this one person who had this
happen to him and then you embed in
there some ethical principle or some
conflict essentially you could tell
three of the trolley problem in some
drama and that would be far more
effective than me given an explanation
with a PowerPoint slide showing
you know the guy on the track and the
five workers and the one worker so are
ya Murray not about categorically yep
yeah so basically if you if you could
spend five years you know studying at
Cambridge with the greatest biblical
scholars of all time and you could get
them to sort of if you could find a
scholar who would basically remove all
of the stuff that can't be empirically
true miracle II proved sorry
but that the lessons were lessons that
you believe to be mystically true you
could come around to those stories
basically you could if you don't think
those things are mutually exclusive that
that's I think we really well yeah yeah
absolutely I mean I I just had Bart Bart
Ehrman on my podcast and asked him this
very thing did you because he was a
Christian for a long time and now he's
an atheist but as it could you be a
Christian and not believe in the literal
resurrection of Jesus you see so I think
it's mythically true psychologically
true whatever he goes yeah lots of
Christians used to believe that that was
kind of the main thing until really just
the last century and a half or so with
the rise of science and the power of
science believers feel like well I I
can't just say it's true for me or it's
you know it's my faith tradition I can't
prove it there's a sense that now you
actually have to make an argument like
this is why it's really true not just
psychologically true and true for me my
faith tradition so creationists went
down this road in the early 20th century
like we have to argue that the flood
really happened okay that means we got
to study geology we got to figure out
how floods do this to that and rocks and
what you know and and and they're still
doing that to a certain extent and it
never gets them anywhere because they
don't have very hey they don't have very
good arguments be science has better
arguments for the flood or whatever and
in any case once you go down that road
you go well what happens if science
fills that gap are you gonna abandon my
Christianity
well no no cuz that's not why I believe
right have you found some people like
that though that that you know they get
to that place and science fills the hole
and then they suddenly walk or do you
find that more people walk from religion
because of some other inconsistency
or some other personal axe to grind or
something like that for personal reasons
is the main reason people leave I mean
there's this meme saying you can't talk
somebody out you can't reason somebody
out of something they didn't reason
their way in the - in the first place
that's not true I do this all we we do
this all the time skeptics and
scientists or whatever and there's in
the research from Hugo Mercier and other
cognitive psychologists that study this
show that you can talk people out of
beliefs you can reason them out but just
collectively on average I think most
people come to religion or they leave
religion for personal reasons
they come there they were raised that
way or their spouses that way or their
their peer group in high school like my
case and and they leave for other
personal reasons you know like after the
Holocaust a lot of Jews became atheists
like where was God
you know this the problem at the Odyssey
again and so in my case when I finally
gave it up in 19th scepter seven years
in the graduate school you know I didn't
tell anybody I just quit talking about
it and I think my family was kind of
relieved because I was always you know
yammering away about you know Jesus and
you know this scene is what it's called
witnessing and I think they were sick of
it so they were like thank God Michael
stopped talking about that and I think
that well now see what happened yeah so
as a guy that now talks about some other
stuff the subtitle of the book is
reflections of a scientific humanist and
you you mention that phrase earlier can
you explain exactly what that is yeah so
humanism has been around really for a
long time secular humanism is a movement
kind of rose in the 30s and 40s very
left-wing liberal you know again free
speech free free thought women's rights
you know the civil rights
african-american rights and on and on
and so that was great but then by the
90s and early 2000s the it kind of
shifted not just further to the left but
also this kind of tribal ticking of the
boxes like here the 12 things secular
humanists believe well well I could take
like eight of the twelve boxes can i
still be a humanist and it became no
you're out
you know if you don't tick all 12 boxes
you're out I forget what you called it
but there was the the narcissism of
small differences yeah yeah I love that
phrase it's a great friend not mine
originally I don't know who came up
alright so that so then and then Pinker
started calling it enlightenment
humanism I like that
sometimes I use that phrase but I
thought but really in those chapters I'm
arguing for that science has something
to say about human values and morals and
ethical theories and so on even if you
can't perfectly debunk the naturalistic
fallacy and go from the way from is to
odd the way things are the way things
they they ought to be maybe technically
that's not possible but again I I don't
care about that I'm just saying this
binary choice between divine command
theory that is God said it and that
makes it right or wrong
versus relativism anything goes there
are no real moral values III just don't
believe that you know as I quote Abraham
Lincoln if slavery is not wrong nothing
is wrong and I say if the Holocaust is
not wrong nothing is wrong show me a
society where people say I will really
want to be enslaved you know when most
people say or where most people in a
group say yeah I really think should be
exterminated I mean this is insane
nobody thinks that we all know why
that's wrong we're barn knowing that
that wrong now set aside crazy
psychopath said just like murdering
people or most of us have a sense of
right and wrong that comes from our
nature so I have long arguments about
the evolutionary origins of morality and
so forth but but the idea again is just
to counter this binary choice you know
that there's more of that so I call it
scientific humanism call it
enlightenment humanism but but let's not
let's not make the tent so small that
only a few people can tick all 12 boxes
that's a that's a bad road to go down
and for some reason a lot of social
movements do that I remember when
objectivism was on the rise when I was
at Pepperdine to mention I everybody
read Atlas Shrugged right and then she
died in 82 and then you know it was this
big movement then a bit but then then
the biographies about her came out that
showed the movement was shrinking as
they were
taking people out like you watched the
wrong films you listen to the wrong
music that's not Objectivist music what
right even smoking the wrong brand of
cigarettes became an that you know the
non Objectivist form of cigarette
smoking it's like pretty soon there's
like six people at her funeral there's
nobody left you know you know it's so
interesting because as you know I I do
some speaking events with the Iran
Institute and I think we've done at
least one together didn't I think we did
something without together maybe it may
be at USC or something and I think
actually they the top brass there I
don't want to speak for them but I think
they really do regret some of exactly
what you're talking about making it so
sort of hysterical in nature but you
know when you mentioned Iran before and
being at Pepperdine it is sort of
interesting because you have all these
people that come from a religious
background reading a book about you know
really from the ultimate individualist
capitalist who truly was a secularist to
because she did a mass dissection of
religion and really was completely anti
religion yet somehow these people were
able to read these things and I guess it
didn't work out that well in the end but
they were able they were trying to put
these pieces together which is kind of
interesting yeah for sure the the new
generation of of Iran supporters are
much more ecumenical about that I mean I
think in in the earlier generation when
Iran was alive I think they said
Friedrich Hayek and Ludwig von Mises and
and Milton Friedman were basically
socialists it's like what I mean these
guys are like hardcore libertarian
they're not libertarian oh yeah yeah
well according to the New York Times
Milton Friedman's Milton Friedman's
leading people to the all right didn't
you know that I mean that's that's how
it works that's right that's right
but again I think all movements do that
yeah so I want to move on to Willie have
a little bit of time left I want to move
on to some of the ways that you tackle
the issues of the day through this lens
so let's talk about guns a little bit
because basically you talk about it's
sort of just the lens that liberals and
conservatives are using to look at the
issue that is is sort of the problem in
the first place
yeah guns is I have a couple chapters in
the book on guns because I did these
debates with John Lott the author of
that book more guns less crime okay
so he's pretty hardcore you see him a
lot on TV defending the Second Amendment
and so on okay fine I'm not a critic of
the Second Amendment I'm concerned about
the levels of gun violence you know 35
to 40 thousand a year die of guns
shouldn't we do something about this
like the automobile industry did this
you know let's put seatbelts in and
airbags and so on and and why doesn't
the gun manufacturers do this the inner
I used to do that the NRA was a gun
safety club that insisted on training
people on the use of guns okay I'm fine
with guns as long as you know you have
training and you keep it locked in a
lock box and so on but the problem is is
that I think the right now has
fetishized the Second Amendment such
that guns are a proxy for something else
it's not the guns they're defending it's
that guns represent freedom autonomy
Liberty the right for me to protect
myself and my family and my home well
isn't that what law enforcement is for
yeah but they can't be there on time and
they're not always reliable
therefore it's up to me it's a very
American way of thinking about this
issue and so I kind of look at some of
those issues in the book - it's a hard
one I know because I have no solution to
this Dave there's 350 million guns in
America we're not gonna confiscate them
all the second amendments not going to
be tossed out it's never gonna happen
and you know but but but the idea like
well shouldn't we just like have
background checks and closed the gun
show loophole and just little things but
the moment you go down that path the you
know people on the far end of that
spectrum they go oh no that's a slippery
slope and pretty soon you know it's
Hitler's marching in the streets taking
away everybody's guns you know come on
we should right so there's these people
talking so much yeah there's so much
there I mean 350 million guns as you say
that's more than people in the United
States I mean that's one thing but do
you think in a time like we're in right
now where the reason we're not doing
this in studio is obviously because of
coronavirus and it's pretty miraculous
we've talked for 50 minutes and not even
mentioned it which is nice but that in a
time like right now where we see stories
where you know New York City's letting
out a certain amount of prisoners and
we're closing gun shops in LA and the
government seems to be taking these what
I would say are strange somewhat radical
measures that it actually feel
needs that sort of very American idea
even if you're not thrilled with that
idea that you could see why someone
would think the way they think yeah yeah
for sure I mean well the gun a couple of
gun rights group sued Newsome and the
state of California insisting that gun
shops are a essential commodity like
pharmacies and supermarkets should stay
open so should gun shops Wow
okay really I mean you know are we are
do you really believe we're even at the
great America is on the precipice of
collapsing at any moment you know the
currency is gonna be useless and within
a matter of weeks there'll be mobs in
the street I better pack a backpack and
heat and have my my home fully loaded up
ready to shoot people you know I mean
come on don't you have more confidence
in the American system of law and order
and civil society than that and
apparently a lot some people don't I
mean I think I really do yeah yeah
listen I wish we could I wish we could
go longer but we're crunched over here
but we will do this in person the second
weekend and we'll pick it up because
there's there's so much more in here
it's a dense thoughtful book and I
really enjoyed it and and this is now at
least your seventh appearance on the
Reuben report so I well thanks to you
now you're one of the you're one of the
people I think of what's giving the
devil you do give the devil their due
and and you get hammered for it but you
know you got to absorb it because that's
the only way I listen to your show all
the time there's people I never even
heard of it's like wow that's an
incredibly interesting idea that's the
only way we can learn and and make
progress indeed my friend while I look
forward to seeing you in person and
it'll be better done than through these
these pipes that I will link will link
to the book right down below if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist there all
right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell